I think you know when we think about
resilience when we started reading
resilience research it was actually done
on people in the worst of circumstances
going through war and poverty and abuse
and it's amazing how widely this
research applied and Cheryl that was one
of the first things that we started
talking about and that theme of
gratitude was really relevant to your
life life too so after I lost Dave just
a few weeks later Adam said to me one
day long before we were working on a
book he said you should think about what
could be worse and I know that things
can be worse I haven't lived through
what malala's was through but you know
when your husband dies suddenly no few
people say to you you should think about
what could be worse most people are
trying to cheer you up
sorry and and I would have thought if
you're trying to escape from deep grief
if you're trying to get through you know
what is the major overwhelming grief and
sadness you should think about positive
thoughts so I looked at Adam like he was
you know absolutely not thinking at all
and he's one of the most brilliant
people I ever met and he said no I mean
it he said Dave could have had that same
cardiac arrhythmia driving your children
and it had never occurred to me and
absolutely I could have lost all three
of them in that same split second and
the minute he said it I did I felt
better I thought to myself okay my kids
are alive I'm okay
and counter-intuitively whenever we face
something that's really hard and it can
be hard and it can be overwhelming
thinking about what could be worse helps
us find gratitude for that which we took
it really for granted before and one of
the major lessons for me
in building resilience how we built it
in ourselves and each other is finding
gratitude for even the most basic things
like the fact that my children were
alive something I never really thought
to be grateful of what grateful for
before